david alors où en est donc cette
mobilisation pour ce nouveau samedi à ce
qu'elle touche à sa fin à bien écouter
le cortège a stagné un boulevard de
belleville à quelques kilomètres des
buttes chaumont un point final de cette
manifestation
une manifestation qui s'est passé dans
le calme un important dispositif de
sécurité était mise en place encore une
fois par le préfet l'allemand
d'importants moyens humains au vieux et
d'istres et disproportionnée au vu du
nombre de manifestants je me trouve
actuellement avec et olivier thériault
syndicalistes de la cgt ratp
olivier pourquoi c'est important d'être
là pour vous aujourd'hui parce que déjà
d'une part je me considère comme un
gilet jaune
c'est important d'être là et je crois
que c'est important dans la période de
participer à l'ensemble des actions qui
peuvent démontrer le voilà le rejette
cette politique qui globalement ne fait
qu'appauvrir une classe de la société
qui est pourtant celle qui fournit la
richesse de ce pays
donc il n'ya pas de question à se poser
pourquoi être là ou là je crois que tous
les endroits où la contestation est
possible il faut là il faut l'alimenter
il faut la faire grandir
et justement cette contestation
populaire al intervient au niveau des
gis l'aude mais aussi au niveau des
syndicats pour la réforme des retraites
la convergence des luttes c'est quelque
chose qui est important qu'est ce que ça
vous évoque vous bat pour qu'ils
convergent et luc faucher des luttes et
ça tombe bien en ce moment il ya pas mal
de lutte il ya d'élus dans beaucoup de
corporation de travailleurs que ce soit
dans la santé que ce soit dans l'énergie
que ce soit dans l'éducation
enfin voilà donc il faut faire converger
toutes ses colères il faut bien les
canaliser faut bien trouver les vrais
responsables et les vrais responsables
se sont quand même nos gouvernants qui
qui prône un système libéral capitaliste
qui nous fout tous dans le mur quoi donc
oui il faut il faut faire converger
toutes ces luttes il faut aussi dénoncer
la manière dont notre gouvernement
répond avec une répression policière qui
nous rappelle quand même des heures
sombres de l'histoire j'ai l'impression
de me retrouver dans la police de papon
avec al donneurs d'ordre qui voilà qui
qui met des forces de police en
puissance avec finalement peu de
manifestants donc qui fait tout pour
dégoûter les gens de venir qui leur fait
peur hein faut pas se raconter
d'histoire et surtout qui met en place
des méthodes pour finalement
criminaliser des gens qui ne viennent
juste que pour faire apparaître leur
mécontentement il ya qu à voir encore ce
qui s'est passé à la cité aujourd'hui ce
qui s'est passé la semaine dernière sur
palais royal où sur opéra enfin c'est
juste pas normal ces méthodes quoi c'est
comment on peut parler d'une démocratie
quand on voit que finalement même le
code déontologique de la police n'est
pas respectée et le droit de manifester
est complètement obstruée pour vous ah
oui moi je pense qu'on fait tout pour
nous empêcher de manifester
on va au delà de ce que la loi permet on
voit aussi qu'on essaie de criminaliser
les grévistes un mois je suis à la ratp
on nous parle de service minimum qu'on
va demain on va peut-être ben changer
encore les règles du service minimum il
faudrait en fait que les grèves ne fasse
pas de bruit quoi c'est ça ils veulent
pas que la contestation s'entendent et
là on le voit il ya un peu plus beaucoup
de grévistes à la ratp ou sncf et c'est
comme s'il y avait plus rien dans les
médias alors qu'en fait ça brûle de
partout
donc moi je pense que très bientôt et
moi c'est un truc que je porte avec
beaucoup de des camarades de la base
c'est peut-être ben pourquoi pas
organiser des semaines complètement noir
de grève de blocage dans ce pays
ça pourrait commencer puis je sais pas
moi le 8 mars avec la journée des droits
de la femme avec une semaine nous on
arrête l'outil de travail un peu partout
et puis on terminerait sur cet appel
national le 14 mars des gilets jaunes
boîte pour ça moi je pense que on aurait
l'occasion de vraiment de rassembler
toutes les colères et je pense qu'il
faut pas s'interdire justement de fixer
un cap pour tout le monde une stratégie
claire qui soit fait un à moyen terme et
qu'ils puissent donc permettre à tout le
monde de s'organiser
que ce soit pour se mettre en grève ou
pour venir je sais pas aussi faire une
montée nationale sur paris près des
lieux de pouvoir
merci beaucoup olivier d'avoir répondu à
nos questions là vous l'aurez compris en
les
revendication pour alléger les jeunes
sont toujours les mêmes la dissolution
de l'assemblée nationale la création
également de conseils d' états généraux
ce citoyen afin de réécrire la
constitution la mobilisation aujourd'hui
était assez importante elle touche à sa
fin ici d'ici quelques heures
pour cet acteur 66 des gilet jaune merci
beaucoup d'avis de khalifa pour toute
assez précise